We have this one that was actually published
in The New York Times
and you can see all the airbrushing all over it.
During the Live Q&A, we can even take this out and look at it from the front and the back
which is really great.
Hi, I'm Sarah Meister.
I'm a curator here in the Department of Photography
at The Museum of Modern Art.
And we're here in our collection storage space
which is super cold
which is why I'm wearing a parka.
Over the last few months, we've been doing
a new Live Q&A series on MoMA's YouTube channel.
So since May is National Photography Month, we thought it would be fun to do one about photography
We're going to explore lots of questions coming
from you
but some of them might have to do with:
Why is it so cold here in the collection storage?
Or how do we select what prints we put on the walls?
How do we choose which print if we have more than one from a given negative?
Or why do analog photos matter in the digital era?
We'll answer both questions and I hope a whole
lot more.
You can leave them in the little comments
section below.
And of course, you can submit them live on
Wednesday, May 23 at 3:00 p.m. New York time.
We also thought it would be fun to pull out
a few photographs
by some of your favorite photographers
so please list those in the comments section
as well
and we'll pick a few of those to share with
everyone.
So until then, enjoy these videos on MoMA's
YouTube channel
and be sure to subscribe so you get an alert
when we go live.